in the sneaker world there's the easy to
find to get them at the mall pairs
then there's the exclusives certain
models can be worth hundreds
if not thousands per pair depending on
the brand year
and colorway for example these jordan
white cement 4s from 2012 have a going
price of just over 400
this has created a niche yet powerful
global market that's akin to art
collecting or trading commodities
the game had a big shake up when a
prominent sneaker reseller
west coast joe of west coast streetwear
revealed his identity in a bloomberg
businessweek story
west coast joe is really joe hebert a 19
year old based in portland oregon
and here's where things go sideways his
mother is anne hebert
nike's general manager and vice
president for north america
she had a career that spanned over 25
years at the sneaker giant
but because of her son that came to a
halt on march 1st
when she voluntarily resigned a nike
spokesperson said in a statement there
was no violation of company policy
sharing of privileged information or
conflict of interest
but the family connection between the
two definitely raised flags
for one it was reported joe hebert used
his mother's credit card to buy about
two thousand pairs of sneakers for
around two hundred thousand dollars
which he hoped would turn a profit of
fifty thousand
one particular scoop that is now highly
suspect is how he managed to find pairs
of 2011 nike air mags
through a man who allegedly stumbled
across them in an abandoned storage unit
these were reproductions of the
futuristic self-lacing shoes marty mcfly
wore
in back to the future too power laces
all right
oh and just so you know the 2011 air
mags are worth
almost 15 000 a pair since the story
took off
neither mother nor son has spoken
publicly in its statement about the
incident
nike also added there were no official
commercial affiliations with west coast
streetwear
including the direct buying and selling
of nike products
you